it's actually weird the way that we do
uh language models right now are all of
the uh information is in the weights and
the human brains don't really like this
with like a hippocampus and a memory
system so why don't llms have a memory
system and there's people working on
them I think future LMS are going to be
like smaller but are going to run
looping on themselves and are going to
have retrieval systems
and the thing about using a retrieval
system is you can cite sources
explicitly um
which is a really helpful to integrate
the human into the loop of the of the
thing because you can go check the
sources and you can investigate so
whenever the thing is hallucinating you
can like have the human supervision so
that's pushing it towards level two kind
of that's going to kill Google
wait which part when someone makes an
llm that's capable of citing its sources
it will kill Google
um that's citing a sources because
that's basically a search engine
that's what people want in the search
engine but also Google might be the
people that build it maybe I put ads on
them I'd count them out
why is that what do you think who who
wins this uh race we've got who who are
the competitors all right we've got tiny
Corp I don't know if that's yeah I mean
you're a legitimate competitor in that
I'm not trying to compete on that you're
not no not as this can accidentally
stumble into that competition
I don't think you might build a search
engine to replace Google search
when I started comma I said over and
over again I'm going to win self-driving
cars I still believe that
I have never said I'm going to win
search with the tiny Corp and I'm never
going to say that because I won't the
Knight is still young we don't you don't
know how hard is it to win search in
this new route like it's
it feels I mean one of the things that
child GPT kind of shows that there could
be a few interesting tricks that really
have that create a really compelling
product some startups gonna figure it
out I think I think if you ask me like
Google's still the number one webpage I
think by the end of the decade Google
won't be the number on my bed anymore
so you don't think Google because of the
how big the corporation is look I I
would put a lot more money on Mark
Zuckerberg
what is that
because Mark Zuckerberg's alive
like this is old Paul Graham essay
startups are either alive or dead
Google's dead
face versus why Facebook is alive Meta
Meta you see what I mean like that's
just like like Mark Zuckerberg this is
Mark Zuckerberg reading that Paul Graham
asking and being like I'm gonna show
everyone how alive we are I'm gonna
change the name
so you don't think there's this
gutsy pivoting engine
that uh like Google doesn't have that
the the kind of engine that the startup
has like constantly you know what being
alive I guess when I listen to Sam
Altman podcast
um he talked about the button everyone
who talks about AI talks about the
button the button to turn it off right
do we have a button to turn off Google
is anybody in the world capable of
shutting Google down
what does that mean exactly the company
or the end of the search engine so we
shot the search engine down we shut the
company down
either
can you elaborate on the value of that
question does Sundar pashai have the
authority to turn off google.com
tomorrow
who has the authority that's a good
question just anyone with anyone
yeah I'm sure
are you sure they have the technical
power but do they have the authority
let's say Sundar pashai made this his
soul Mission came into Google tomorrow
and said I'm going to shut google.com
down yeah
I don't think you keep this position too
long
and what is the mechanism by which he
wouldn't keep his position well the
boards and shares and corporate
undermining and oh my God our revenue is
zero now
okay so what I mean what's the case
you're making here so the the capitalist
machine prevents you from having the
button yeah and it will have it I mean
this is true for the AIS too right
there's no turning the AIS off
there's no button you can't press it now
does Mark Zuckerberg have that button
for facebook.com
yes probably more I think he does I
think he does and this is exactly what I
mean and why I bet on him so much more
than I bet on Google I guess you could
say Elon has similar stuff our Elon has
the button yeah
Does Elon can Elon Fire the missiles can
he fire the missiles
I think some questions are better
unasked right
I mean you know a rocketed an ICBM like
a rocket that can land anyway isn't that
an ICBM well yeah you know don't ask too
many questions
oh my God
uh but the the positive side of the
button is that you can innovate
aggressively is what you're saying is
which is what's required with uh turning
llm into a search engine I would bet on
a startup I better because it's so easy
right I've been on something that looks
like mid-journey but for search
just is able to say sources loop on
itself I mean it just feels like one
model can take off yeah right and a nice
rapper and some of it it's scary it's
hard to uh like create a product that
just works really nicely stably the
other thing that's going to be cool is
there is some aspect of a winner take
all effect right like once um someone
starts deploying a product that gets a
lot of usage and you see this with open
AI uh they are going to get the data set
to train future versions of the model
yeah um they are going to be able to
right uh you know I was asked a Google
image search when I worked there like
almost 15 years ago now how does Google
know which image is an apple and I said
the metadata and they're like yeah that
works about half the time how does
Google know you'll see they're all
apples on the front page when you search
Apple
and uh I don't know I didn't come up
with the answer the guy's like well it's
what people click on when they search
Apple I'm like oh yeah yeah yeah that
data is really really powerful it's the
human supervision